what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how's it
going john is good today how is greg
greg going good thank you for asking
good greg good job guys we're gonna
watch brooklyn nine-nine what episode in
season is this the season 20 episode 3
episode that's what we're doing today
people ladies and gentlemen leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated and also
sometimes it feels good to just sit back
maybe even lay down and enjoy yourself a
good comedy and sometimes it's even
great when you can do that with a
sponsor that you're actually really
grateful to be working with because you
actually use their product so thank you
to today's video sponsor helix thank you
to helix sleep for sponsoring this video
so guys as we've been partnering up with
certain brands we've been fortunate
enough to be in the position of work
with brands that we actually truly
believe in and love that is not a
talking point that is me just talking
from my heart right now we are so
fortunate to work with them they
actually make really high quality
premium mattresses customized to fit
your needs conveniently shipped right to
your door uh both john and i each got a
bed the twilight lux it's the second
firmest mattress that they have where i
live now we actually have a back house
and some of you guys might know this i
recently got the vid diesel so to
quarantine you know keep my fiance safe
i stayed in the back house and over
there is where we set up the helix
mattress it was super easy john actually
has footage of him setting up his he
just opened the box on roll it cut the
plastic watch it inflate uh two of us
doing it together it only took like less
than 10 minutes it was the easiest bed
set i've ever did in my life but
sleeping in that bed i already have a
bed in our master bedroom i did not set
up the helix there because i was like
whatever we just got this bed throw it
in the back house
that uh is a decision i will forever
regret
because now we have someone renting that
back house and they get to enjoy that
bed really while i had the vid diesel
while i was recovering it was some of
the best sleep i've ever had my back
actually felt so much better i would
find myself just wanting to be like
maybe i could turn this backhouse into
my own little man cave and i could just
sleep back here and watch tv it is such
a comfy bed i'm telling you guys we are
so fortunate to work with them yeah it's
really easy to get set up you take a
quick quiz online at helixsleep.com they
will match you to the best fit for your
sleep style and they will ship it to you
with a 100 night trial period so if you
don't like it for any reason you could
send it back get a 10 year warranty they
really take the risk out of the whole
situation for you so yeah click that
link in the description box helix sleep
dot com slash real rejects to save
yourself 200
on your mattress plus you get two free
pillows and free shipping in the united
states oh yeah guys thank you helix for
your support supported them supports us
so yeah all right on to the video
while captain holt's out of town at his
conference i'm in charge jake i ordered
you to throw out that gingerbread house
guess who got their dealer nice chasing
through a subway tunnel back up through
a storm drain adrian and i got engaged
and then we busted him with towers
the getting engaged part oh yeah we got
engaged engaged engaged seriously yeah i
don't want to toot my own horn or
anything but it was super romantic
you follow i'll cut him off in the alley
okay wait you want to get married
[Laughter]
god yep adrian pimento adrian is about
to ask you to be his best man i need you
to say yes and i need you to act
surprised no problem check this out
best man
sarge does not approve of the wedding
and honestly it is killing me i'm sure
you're just reading into it no
what are you doing pimento was nuts
anyway i think sarge would like him if
he actually got to know him so during
the bachelor party i need you to show
him the real adrian i will make sure
sarge loves him great
crap here comes adrian you never saw me
all right
so who are you thinking about inviting
to the bachelor party maybe like i don't
know terry's great probably terry is
available i could ask him sure no i was
thinking all the guys from work except
chuck rosa called dibs on him maid of
honor
yes
count me in as long as i get eight plus
ones guys
focus we need to start planning so
when's the wedding next summer next fall
next winter next week next week
don't worry about that stuff one dumb
wedding thing i've always wanted was a
bachelorette party all the pressure's on
that one event cool cool very cool i'm
not sleeping for the next 24 hours hey
man male strippers chip and dale i'm
surprised he didn't want us all to get
drunk and slash each other with machetes
he's not exactly stable
no he's dead
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't use frazier's name in vain copy
that yeah sorry if chase wants to pay
for us to have a fun night out let's not
stop it i'm not paying for it we're
splitting it well then i'm with terry
this wedding's a shame
wow how cool is this tv on a bus i never
thought i'd see that who doesn't show up
on time for their own party look you
said you'd keep an open mind with
pimento he'll show just give him a shot
is everybody comfortable back there does
anybody need anything
whoa
we need to go now
someone's trying to kill me mine clothes
jake my clothes
i might be telling the truth i bet he is
[Music]
look i know you're upset because pimento
seems a little amped up we were going 90
with the headlights off
you ask him in a supportive
non-confrontational manner he'll give
you a calm logical answer fine why do
you want to know who are you working for
i will cut you
hey uh adrian where are you
we're all on your side here pimento we
all want to believe that you're about to
be murdered thanks man
[Laughter]
here's everything i know it all started
take a word please what i don't know
everybody else got to go outside get
back on
zane rational sarge what do you think
fine we can go but only to prove he's
making this all up okay okay the
important thing is you agreed we can go
and you and pimento are best friends now
let's do it
tonight we will be attending my nephew
anthony's 13th birthday party that
sounds awful which is what we're gonna
do it's a paintball party nice let's go
shoot my nephew
we playing a lead
a lead
oh
oops
well well well guess i nailed it
pressure's on guys good
pressure is my jam
that building right there if figgis
hired him that means he's highly trained
armed and very dangerous the only
problem is none of us are packing oh not
a problem i've got an arsenal in my
pants
[Music]
okay look this was maybe a weird way to
start the night but the good news is we
can still make our dinner reservation
and no one got hurt actually i cut
myself real bad of course you did
it's a drinking game get a question
wrong do a shot oh and the questions
they're all about rosa but none of us
know anything about rosa what is my
favorite soup chicken noodle potato leek
i was a baby my first word was dada
[Music]
i can totally do a handstand
oh yeah
i'd like to make a toast to the groom to
be adrian pimento don't bother jake
everybody's pissed at me no no we're not
we're all supporting you we're doing
shepherd checks right i told you we're
splitting it
and i'm sorry that earlier i went a
little off the rails stole all of your
wallets to double check your identities
right but with friends like you finally
starting to feel like there he is
oh no
sarge look
a gun and a picture of pimento
what do you have to say now
someone's trying to kill him that's
right in your face
[Laughter]
look i'm sorry i doubted you i'm also
sorry that someone's trying to kill you
but i can really only take ownership for
the first part well personally i think i
also deserve an apology
no okay that's totally cool so what's
our plan
car battery jumper cables and unfettered
access to his nibs maybe i should ask
the questions hey jakey if you're asking
the waiter questions find out when the
mashed potatoes are coming he's not a
real winner
i'm a contract killer who is hired to
kill agent pimento who wants me dead i i
don't know i haven't met the guy once i
finish the job i'm supposed to text him
a photo of the body then we meet up and
i get them staged pimento's death and go
to the meetup ourselves i thought of it
before you did whatever let's just do
sarge's thing i guess
where are we going a restaurant that
petite colon it means small intestine
because that's all they serve which is
why they shut it down we
are demolishing it
i've been dreaming about this since i
was a little girl
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's actually
you need to make my main man pimento
look super murdered like tarantino
disgusting murdered sarge blood
head shot
damn it feels good to be creative again
and here comes the brains
ugh
nice photo taken scent yes and he wants
me to bring him your tongue oh
how did i not see this coming he's
always eating weird stuff like tongues
and chicken faces oh and he's already
texted me back with a top 10 list
you have a tongue yeah it's all there
jimmy figgis thanks you
he works for figgis he's new where's he
going now
that's the fbi building
holy
[ __ ] just stay calm and be methodical
right jimmy the butcher figgis has a man
in the fbi and he tried to have pimento
kill and i cut my other cheek how i took
the knife away from you oh man
right now they think i'm dead this is my
only chance to get away safe jake
i need you to tell rosa that i love her
okay no
saying goodbye to her you owe her that
much it's just
too dangerous goodbye nine-nine and with
that i left
[Music]
man he wanted me to tell you that he
loves you is that it did he say anything
else may the lord be with you
adrian
oh thank god
i was burning my fingerprints off in a
gas station bathroom when i thought
about what jake said i couldn't leave
without seeing one last time i want to
lick your whole body clean like a kitty
cat yeah i'm going to give you too
little space
[Laughter]
and while i'm waiting i will find that
fbi agent and i will rip his head off
with my bare hands
that is the sweetest thing anybody's
ever said to me i love you i love you
oh
it's not fair sergeant jeffords briefed
me about the pimento situation he's in
the episode
he had a large scar on his right palm
i have a similar scar on my back banged
into amy's kitchen cabinet no big deal
continue
detective pimento's a good man and he's
one of us so let's catch these bastards
for him
and rosa
nine-nine discreetly jacob nine-nine
oh that was phenomenal
the whole episode was phenomenal yeah it
was a great one such great rhythm
that's such a great game too
yeah them competing uh competing
bachelor parties so well edited it was
like top v99 right there
i loved that so much
it was it was not only like the bits
were just so well done i love a good
like any comedy sitcom you know bachelor
bachelorette party i've seen it done in
death so many times but this was so
creative in the way it was executed
um
like
i loved you talk first
no i absolutely agree i mean this was
yeah it was like all the characters were
used just the right way yeah yeah okay
so here's what i want to know
go ahead
no yeah i don't know it it's one of
those episodes that that actually
incorporates the cold open and the cold
open was so funny but then
it i don't know it just swept off into
this like really inspired it's like okay
i guess we're doing this and yeah like
the way it played games with the
characters but also you know
bothered to have it be something of a
real story with actual stakes it's like
there were moments where i was like oh
my god is he actually about to leave the
show like is this you know i don't know
there are times when they make
characters get together or get married
or whatever and you feel like okay this
is just gonna be a gimmick but i started
to lose the sort of track of you know
trying to figure it out in your head and
i just got sucked into the fun but also
just the story at hand and the sort of
mystery of like yeah what's going on is
he actually being pursued by somebody
and it was about the time i think when
when uh jake texts charles about the
tongue i was like
the part of what's so brilliant about
this episode is it feels like everyone's
together even though they're not like
the timelines yeah sync up really well
and they're both like two you know
they're mirrors they're two halves of
the same coin but they're also totally
different stories happening so i like
that you have a personal bonding story
but then you also have like a more mad
cap
you know actual crime story and it
actually got uh it's pretty emotional at
the end there
because need to have how like rosa's
night is escalating to the best night
ever yeah
and then
um
oh my god what's jason
and then pimento's night is
de-escalating yes it's getting worse and
worse
and so he does reach this like pinnacle
point
where you know makes sen like i make
sense why he feels like white have to go
into hiding it's an fbi agent and then
her ending on that note where it's like
sweet with the people at the end of the
bachelorette party i'm like i'm so
excited the rest of my life like it was
so sincere you get to see a time where
she actually gets emotional and they
kept it at the right pitch perfect note
with them saying bye to each other with
just enough humor but not not too much
to the point where it undercuts some of
the sweetness yeah totally like it was
tender i felt real it was heartbroken
for her in that moment
and it was making me go no one to
spencer christopher tracy it was so
funny he said yeah and it was so wacky
like the bachelor party the bachelor
party itself was so wacky
uh and i love the wackiness of how it
unfolded with jake having to maintain
and manage everything and then
the quick cuts to having to talk to
people to calm them down
yeah
rotating in and out of them but then
even with uh pimento and
having all the weapons packed with like
this giant arsenal of things it felt
like very phil lord and chris miller
yeah this specific episode i doubt they
directed it but it felt like work into
that style yeah absolutely and i like
that you have like you know with rosa
obviously it's
you usually expect her to be
disappointed with things but i love the
escalation of like yeah each
even though they're all in competition
each one just does get progressively
better and it's also fun to wat like
each of the bits is fun watching them
throw down on the kids and the paintball
range is fun the drinking game like i
like that too we were talking before
about like sometimes they
make amy a bit too much of like ah you
know stick in the mud nerd but like here
it's like these this is one of those
episodes where it's like oh perfect you
know like yeah this this setup is very
you but then it's something that
everyone can get into and there's
like the the yeah i like how they all
turned out good yeah exactly and rosa
turned out to enjoy all of them but two
in the you know kind of
the um you know you just look back over
the way all the different character
relationships have evolved and i was
like i like the charles like she singled
out charles like he's the one who's the
best
you know like i thought that was a cool
way to kind of
just show like the the relationship
journey between the two of them too from
you know him you know like crushing on
her a ton to them just actually becoming
really good friends and colleagues
didn't you have an idea
oh to to they made this a real thing now
is uh
you can go to specific places where yeah
you just pay for time and then you can
wreck stuff
so
so yeah i was like i i'm sure you know
somebody else came up with it too
because they exist now but yeah i think
there's one in la somewhere
just destroy stuff yeah you just get
like a you know a coverall and you know
a big mallet and stuff and they have
just like [ __ ] that you can destroy it's
like
i've seen people take pictures as like
like a tv and
glass and yeah you just kind of how much
does it cost
that's a great question 10 000
i think in fact i think the name is a
pun i think it's the one around here is
called rec room maybe
yeah rec room los angeles let's see
la's rage room and axe throwing look at
that you can get a groupon deal let's
see let's just destroy stuff one hour of
axe throwing but now we wanted to get
destruction let's see
yeah break smash destroy
tickets
this is this is okay here we go we're
finally here come on andrew book in the
ring
all right
suitable for ages 10 and over there's a
glow-in-the-dark experience
they have powerful speakers so you can
put on your music and stuff
you can bring your own stuff to break
there's a points system i want to know
the cost okay
[Music]
god damn
okay it's taking the tickets page i
swear it's gonna be worth it it's gonna
be worth it i mean if an hour of acts
throwing was like 50 bucks like an hour
of destroying stuff has to be around
that 50 to 100 range
i don't want to sign a waiver just to
get to this
all right fine i'm clicking to sign the
waiver you've convinced me now
just give me the rates
how much
is an hour at rec room god damn it
oh prices start at 25
okay now if i wanted to
if i wanted to
torture a live person
um
oh i've got a web browser you should try
a web browser mm-hmm
oh you want to do it yourself i want to
do it myself okay
it kind of excites me mm-hmm
i can see that yeah it's actually a real
rush we could probably arrange for
something like that there are a lot of
like empty abandoned spaces we could
start squatting in and then you could
you know carry out operations there
because you know
can i record it
if you want to
i think i'd watch it all the time yeah
yeah and then you it's but but that's
the thing is you'd watch it so much that
then you'd have to make more
yeah because you're gonna get you're
gonna eat a bigger rush than that one a
weekly thing yeah i think i'd enjoy my
life more yeah definitely and there are
definitely people we could thin out of
the uh i don't want to kill that
population
okay but i don't want them to know it's
me
that's part of what makes it fun
i just want to
you're not going to kill them you're
just going to like you know severely
maim them
yeah yeah
anonymously that's far what excites me
whenever where they go
they'll never know who never know they
think about this every day
you know and you should taunt them you
should give them like clues about
yourself
but that they could never actually
figure out that are about you
i do reaction channels
oh and then if you need to throw off you
know your scent then you can just start
framing your friends
i mostly cover marvel news
i do breakdowns and endings explained
when he killed that bug that was so
funny i know
he's great i hope that he's not actually
leaving for real
cause he's so much fun i love him he's
perfect for the cast yeah he like
perfectly fits in
he does and i i really
like i could see it being just like a
few episodes but part of me is like i
can see him just being part of the show
forever
he's he's he's he adds a great amount of
like unpredictable life to any pairing
they do with him as long as they don't
make him the star yeah
like he like if you do too much of him
in a row it can be overwhelming but if
you're like
you know you have a few episodes that
are focused on him don't make it the
hangover three where you take the side
character
who works because they're a side
character and then you make them the
lead
all right let's do a patron the day shot
everett pixel my baker if there's anyone
we would kidnap and beat up anonymously
it would be you
let's test that pixel might this is
going to be a growing experience for you
maybe you'll overpower us and get out of
it you know
and then where would we be keep going
that's right man we're gonna we're gonna
come to like where you work maybe we're
gonna put a bag on your head and we're
gonna transport you but we're gonna do
it really gently because we don't want
to hurt you until we intended to hurt
you so
just don't towing that good line of uh i
don't think you should tow it i think
you got to go into
getting canceled pledged yeah yeah
absolutely so we're going to take you to
an undisclosed location we're just gonna
like throw you on the ground and be like
hahaha this is what you get for joining
the patreon everett baker
and then you're gonna be like oh i only
joined one patreon i bet i know who's
behind this and we're gonna be like nuh
uh and that's the point at which we
start like you know kicking you
and then maybe we'll get like a blow
torch and we'll like burn you with the
blowtorch and then we'll we'll start
whipping out like more creative things
like we'll get like a medieval flail out
there we go jesus taking so long yeah
yeah we'll get some like leather whips
and stuff like that and we'll hook you
up to a car battery
yeah and then we'll get some uh some
live piranhas and we're gonna you know
put them
all over you and we're gonna cover you
in something tasty we're gonna cover you
in chum and fish guts so the piranhas
are just like oh we gotta eat this guy
right here right now and we're gonna
film it we're gonna put on the internet
and we're gonna sell it as a live stream
here on youtube
and and then get demonetized and then
we're gonna flee and then come back in
different clothes unmasked and then be
like
everett everybody are you okay oh my god
oh my god here let's take you to the
hospital and they tried to frame us
we're heroes then and then we're heroes
for saving your life
and then
yeah
and then you'll have to stay powerless
because we saved you that was disgusting
and i'm sorry
you went too far i'm leaving i had to
say it was thank you everett thank you
everett
now you've made him very uncomfortable
watch the reviews so that you understand
the context yeah if you don't watch the
reviews just skip to your shout out
you're gonna be like what the hell was
that about
no we you know no we love you
it's it's all it's it's jokes we're done
thank you everett
[Music]